today we have two stories about russian
prisons quite frankly um a number of you
wrote to me yesterday
and you sent me an article about a
teacher being imprisoned for political
speech in russia and said david is this
the woman who called into your show a
few months ago now i i've already looked
i don't believe it is the same woman
unless the woman who called in was
deliberately giving wrong information
about where she teaches and different
things but
it is a very cautionary tale about what
exactly was said by our caller and what
she feared because of her political view
so let me reset it for you
um article says russian teacher
sentenced for telling students about war
crimes in ukraine
this article is about irina genn
who received a five-year suspended
sentence and has been barred from
working in state schools and if you read
the article it says this is a school
teacher in a provincial provincial
russian city she got a suspended
sentence because she spoke out against
the kremlin's invasion of ukraine
and uh she was found guilty of
discrediting the russian armed forces
there's a new law that bans criticism of
the war in ukraine
and she got a five-year suspended
sentence and is barred from working in
state schools for three years
the court also found that she
disseminated false information
by telling students about the siege of
mario paul and russian airstrikes
killing children in ukraine
she was slapped with charges in march so
this was actually this predates our
caller but remember
the caller we had
who called in under a pseudonym
for exactly these types of fears listen
to this taking my question so before you
go
you're calling from russia
yeah from moscow and so
what is the would you say the general
sentiment there is that people like the
invasion of ukraine or people are
against the invasion of ukraine
uh i have to say that i will have a
certain moscow liberal bias because
that's the area where i was raised and
my family has always been uh critical of
the government uh there is not a single
person in my immediate uh circles that
are fans of this government okay but i
would say that uh just from my own
personal experience just looking at cars
or driving or parking anywhere i don't
see a single z
sign there is no single i would say
personal initiative to install anything
that is commemorative to this war
all i've seen is state council local
efforts which are sponsored from the
state from the federal budget to try and
convince people to engage in such
practices and some type of coercion
that's happening for example in
kindergartens oftentimes parents
discover that the school trip or the
kindergarten trip they send their
children to was actually a sort of
patriotic
event
because they then later find pictures of
the children posed in the letter z on
social media
that's the patriotic education trump
keeps talking about now listen do you
feel safe expressing your views
antagonistic to the government
on here yes uh over at my university
i've already sort of spoken myself into
15 years of prison if anybody would like
deep
dig anywhere around me
so um this is just a weird stasis that i
know that if anybody looked at me or
what i've been writing what i've been
saying it is quite possible that i will
face some sort of fine or maybe even
jail time after all a person was
arrested yesterday for working out with
a printout of russian constitution onto
the streets
so
obviously not the same person our caller
called in may and we know that irene
again
was already under prosecution starting
in march so not the same caller but
these are not unfounded fears and
thankfully irene again has only received
a suspended sentence and can no longer
teach in state schools and will not be
imprisoned but these are real concerns
and this is what uh so many right
wingers are impressed with quite frankly
this is the type of they they find putin
to be incredibly strong it's sort of
like when duterte is strong because
he encourages the killing of drug
dealers it is a crazy world out there
and these authoritarians are actually
gaining support around the world
including from americans uh in the
united states in the american right wing
very scary stuff
who doesn't love a good cereal the
crunchiness the sweetness it satisfies
in a serious manner but then you grow up
and now all the healthy cereals are
boring and bland and they get soggy and
this is where magic spoon comes in it is
that sweet crunchy texture you loved
from childhood with zero grams of sugar
only four to five net carbs perfect if
you're doing keto only 140 calories per
serving and packed with 14 to 15 grams
of protein magic spoon spent years
developing the recipes it's really the
only cereal on the market to get the
texture and the flavor right without the
sugar and without a ton of carbs they
have flavors like cocoa honey nut fruity
peanut butter maybe you want to go
adventurous they've got blueberry muffin
maple waffle cookies and cream or
cinnamon roll that brings back memories
i love magic spoon the whole team does
but if you don't you'll get a full
refund but i know it's about to become
your new favorite cereal
you'll get five dollars off when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman the link is down below